Mr President thank you for having us
thank you last week you're in New York
for this arraignment the world watched
it you've not given an interview since
you were there I think 57 minutes tell
us from your perspective what that was
like well it was a horrible thing
because I did nothing wrong absolutely
nothing you look at even the pundits and
the legal analysis Greg Jarrett all of
these really talented people they're
saying he didn't do anything wrong so
that's number one number two they were
incredible when I went to the courthouse
which is also a prison in a sense uh
they signed me in
and I'll tell you people were crying
people that worked there professionally
work there that have no problems putting
in murderers and they see everybody
it's tough tough place
and they were crying they were actually
crying they said I'm sorry they'd say
2024 sir 2024
and tears are pouring down there is I've
never seen anything like the those
people are phenomenal those are your
police yep those are the people that
work at the courthouse they're
unbelievable people
many of them were in tears or close to
it
uh many apologists we're sorry sir we're
sorry they had a had me do certain
things they said sir I can't believe I
have to ask you I can't even believe
that I have to ask you to do it you
could see
so in one sense it was beautiful because
they get it uh in another sense you know
it's nasty I went to the Wharton School
of Finance they didn't teach me about
that that wasn't it
part that wasn't that wasn't we didn't
have a class on arraignment and uh you
know it's it was a sad day in many ways
there are many days ways it was a
beautiful day because the people
understand I didn't know this was
happening but the poll numbers have gone
through the roof
the people get it and the other ones are
hoaxes also you know the Box hoax okay
Biden he's got 1850 boxes and you know
that's a hoax and then the one in
Atlanta where had a perfect phone call
this is all weaponization they're
weaponizing our justice system Tucker
and they think if they go and give you a
subpoena
you know I guess I'm very well known and
people understand it and they get it and
maybe I have a bigger platform so I can
explain it but if you're somebody a
republican let's say running for office
and you get a subpoena
you might as well resign because you're
not going to be able to survive it and
the voters aren't going to handle it the
voters aren't going to take it what
they're doing is weaponizing the system
and there's never been anything like it
and it's all disinformation you see the
other day uh
Afghanistan one of the worst things I've
ever seen I think the most embarrassing
moment that this country has ever had
frankly the way we got not the getting
out we had to get out it was ridiculous
to be there and I had that so good so
tight so tough I spoke to the leader
Abdul I said Abdul if you do anything
you're going to get hit really hard
literally I even he said
but so why why he goes why oh why do you
send me a picture of my house I said
you'll have to figure that one out Abdul
but we didn't have one death in 18
months he knew not one death and then to
see the way we got out like we were
surrendering like taking the military
out first leaving 85 billion dollars
worth of equipment behind giving up
Bagram I was going to keep Bagram I was
getting out but not for Afghanistan it's
one hour away from where China makes its
nuclear weapons
it's one of the biggest Air Force bases
in the world I think the biggest with
the runways that go ten thousand feet I
was keeping that
because of China not because of
Afghanistan right and they they left
everything they they left in the dark of
night they left the lights on they left
the dogs by the way you know the people
they love about the dogs they left the
dogs everyone you know the dog lovers
and you got a lot of them I love dogs
you love dogs
but they left their dogs people said
what one of the first questions I got
what did they do with the dogs mostly
German Shepherds they left them uh what
they did the way they got out was so
horrible okay everybody knows that was
their plan that had nothing to do with
me I was getting out too we would have
gotten out with strength and dignity
and what happened they got out and the
other day I hear yeah it was uh Trump's
fault oh that's right it was Trump's
Trump
I was gone for a long I would have been
out faster than them we would have had
all the equipment we would have had the
American citizens we left hostages we
left Americans behind many I think many
more than you think uh and we had 13
soldiers killed and nobody ever mentions
the fact that we had many maimed so
badly
no arms no legs their face was
obliterated
this is the way this guy got out we
would have gotten out with dignity and
strength we were going to
but I was taking a hundred percent of I
said I want every nail I want every
screw I want the tents they said sir the
tents are very hard to take out I said I
want the tents I want the tanks I want
the planes I want everything and a
couple of them fought me on it like
Millie he said sir I think it's cheaper
to leave the equipment behind
I said let me ask you we have a plan
that cost a hundred million dollars it's
sitting there all it needs is a tank of
gas right give me a little jet fuel
we'll fly it to Pakistan or any place
else or we'll fly directly home
you say it's cheaper to leave a hundred
million dollar plan sir I think overall
it's cheaper
these are idiots we're dealing with they
left 85 billion dollars worth of
equipment they left their American
citizens behind and they moved the
military at first no you move the
military At Last I did a little skit
with a five-year-old kid I said let me
ask you here's the situation explained
the situation I said would you take the
military out first or would you take it
out last I took it out last
five-year-old
but they took the military out first and
they were afraid of our military when I
was there they were afraid
we didn't have one soldier killed
in 18 months okay not one soldier was
killed in 18 months and then we got out
like we surrendered I think it was the
single most embarrassing day in the
history of our country it was totally
their fault they didn't go by anything
because you know we had a system of
getting out but if the Taliban in
particular the Taliban because that's
where the action was right when I called
Abdul
the Press went crazy the fake news went
crazy why did he call an enemy
I said well it's Jesse James I used to
ask him why did he rob banks he said
that's where the money is why did I call
the head of the Taliban because that's
where the killing was
and he's there now Abdul I'm sure he
likes me call me your Excellency I don't
know if he calls Biden you're Excellency
probably I mean
you know they're one of the largest arms
dealers now in the world they're selling
the 85 billion dollars worth of because
they only need five percent of it of
course they're selling the equipment
they're one of the largest I think
second
armsdale is a brand new helicopters
brand new airplanes brand new tanks
unbelievable what we left behind we ran
and there was no reason to I had them I
could have stayed there for five years
if I wanted to I wanted out 21 years was
enough I wanted to we shouldn't have
been there in the first place
but when I see what happens when I see
the level of stupidity and because of
that it's all a big web
because of that I think Putin who would
have never gone into Ukraine when I was
there would have never I talked to him
about it often would have never ever
done that when he saw that
I wasn't there and he saw these fools
these stupid people
and think of that the way they left
Afghanistan and nobody was fired I fired
a lot of people because if they didn't
do a good job at Farmers may I asked you
talked to Putin about Ukraine what did
you say to him uh I could see that he
loved it and I said uh he loved Ukraine
he considers it to be a part
of Russia yeah I said not one
unprecedented we had a very
good relationship he was he I mean look
I was the worst thing that ever happened
to him I closed up his pipeline
you never heard the word the words
Nordstrom 2 until I came along Nordstrom
2 was their pipeline
and I had a great relationship with him
but it was very tough because they had a
fake Russia investigation and I told him
and he told me he said it's very hard
for us to deal don't you think I said
very hard because we have a fake
investigation that turned out to be a
fake for two years that went on
and we could have done very well with
Russia they have great minerals they
have great things that we want we could
have and they need the money and they
need other things
but that interfered that was a terrible
thing that was actually a treasonous
thing to do
those people should have been arrested
they made it up they made up a problem
with Russia that didn't exist now
they've all admitted it didn't exist it
was just on to the next one
I often say
they said to me the other day one of
your fellow journalists said who's the
biggest problem sir is it China could it
be Russia could it be North Korea no I
said the biggest problem is from within
it's these sick radical people
from within because we can handle if
we're smart we can handle Russia China
I did
I took in billions and billions hundreds
of billions of dollars from China no
other president took in anything and
they respected me he's the same thing
you know
I told them you can't go into Taiwan you
can't you can't do it I won't tell you
exactly what I said but it was something
that probably a lot of people wouldn't
like if they heard it but it was very
tough don't go into Taiwan if you do
we're gonna have problems other than
that we're going to be
great relationship we're gonna have a
great relationship
and he said to me when I said we're
going to do something if he goes and no
no you wouldn't do I'll do that I swear
I'll do that
and he didn't believe me but he believed
me 10 the same thing with Putin I said I
was going to do something really nasty
if he goes into Ukraine he said no no
you're not going to do that I said I
will
and he didn't believe me either but he
believed me 10 percent
and the 10 you never heard talk about
going into Ukraine you never heard talk
about going into Taiwan
until I was no longer there
now what a mess the world is in what a
mess
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight